Hello,
and welcome to lecture one of the complete
guide of InfluxDB
two.
My name is
wow, confusing.
My name is David Flanagan. I will be
your guide to InfluxDB two. And I just
want to start these sessions by talking a
little bit about how they're gonna work
and other future sessions that will be coming
soon.
So live courses on the Rawkode Academy are
a mixture of live streams just like this,
which will be driven by some live coding,
some slides like we'll see today,
and live q and a's. We'll be doing
these multiple times per week to just try
and engage and make sure that the course
material is being absorbed and consumed and, you
know, we're all learning.
Will also be
prerecorded videos which accompany
each of these live sessions,
which will break down into smaller components each
of the each of the sections of the
workshops that we'll be tackling and and playing
with over the next days and weeks.
So they're multifaceted.
I really hope you enjoy them. I would
love any feedback that you as incubating members
are happy to give to me. So jump
into the Discord. Don't forget, Rawkode. Chat is
the best place to come in. There is
the incubating lounge. If you're not already added
to the incubating lounge and there are a
few of you that I know are not
in there, then remember to connect your YouTube
and your Discords together
so you can join the other members and
chat about these courses.
And also please make suggestions for other courses
you're going to see coming along at the
Rawkode Academy.
I will do my best to make that
happen either guided by myself or guided by
friends that I've got in the community, a
cloud native community.
Okay. That being said, we're gonna start today's
first live session. This should be around thirty
to forty minutes long. We're gonna talk about
the history of time series, and then I'll
give you a little bit of information on
what is coming next week.
Let's get started.
This is an introduction to time series, lecture
one in this course.
Let me get my mouse in the right
place.
Mouse mouse. There we go.
Well, I'm gonna start with a little bit
of a pop quiz. I don't just want
to
throw the time series at you and be
like, hey, this is time series. Like, let's
make it a little bit fun along the
way. So we're gonna start with a little
bit of a pop quiz
just to talk about the history of computing
and time series side by side,
and we'll see how we got. Now I
know I can't receive any of your answers
because
of the what is that annoying thing in
the corner?
I know I can't take any questions from
you right now, but that's okay. Feel free
to leave them in the comments. I will
do my best to tackle them.
Encoding.
Now when I talk about encoding, I'm talking
about as, you know, computer scientists and engineers,
programmers, whatever you want to call yourself,
is our ability to transfer
some piece of information
in a format that isn't the raw format.
You know, base 64 would be an example
of encoding our ability to translate messages into
other formats.
And when we think about this,
you probably think that's relatively new.
I'll give you two seconds to pack your
numbers in your head and see if you're
close.
One, two.
And the answer is no. Encoding
well, not specifically to do with computers, of
course, but encoding goes back many, many, many
years.
First used, at least as far as I
could see, in April.
An eyephant is documented in The Lies of
the Noble Grecians and Romans by Roman historian
Plutarch,
where Plutarch is telling us about the story
of Alcibiades.
Alcibiades was a mercenary who had a fleet
of ships and people by his side, and
he didn't really have allegiance to anyone
except himself.
So when Alkabates would show up to
a war in the seas,
it wasn't until he raised the seine
that people knew which side of that battle
Alkabates was gonna be on.
So that's encoding a message of support
through a flag on a ship.
Now, of course,
it took a long time before this system
really changed.
Know, according to everything I can find online
about flag systems,
it wasn't until the fourteenth century
that they actually evolved to have, like, two
signals, and that was, like, one or two
flags. And this is from the Black Book
of Admiralty.
Although just a hundred years after that, things
did evolve much quicker. I think people realized
maybe there was a flaw in their one
and two flag system.
But by the fifteenth century, it had 15
flags and each flag had a different encoding
or message,
symbol, etcetera on the flag, which all had
different meanings. So you have to understand what
each of the flags meant to know which
message was being passed.
And then a few hundred years later, we
have the French system, which I will fail
to pronounce,
which has 10 coloured flags each representing zero
to nine, and generally these chips would have
three sets of those flags being able to
transfer tuples of information to the other chips
with a big book to look up which
each system means.
Now I'll do one more of these, of
course, based on the encoding one, you know
that I'm using the term encoding loosely. The
same will be true for sharding. So I'll
give you a few seconds to guess. Where
do you think sharding or what was the
oldest reference to anything I could find
that resembled sharding?
And I'm going back to January
this time.
The first documented
example of charting I found
was actually described by Polybius,
and this is talking about the way that
the ancient Romans transferred messages on the battlefield.
Common theme, but not important to today's conversation,
is that ancient battles drive the innovation of
their time.
Now what the ancient Romans
were doing was splitting their alphabet into five
parts
and
using tablets.
So
they would have five tablets
and they would use these to transfer messages
really, really quickly or at least yeah, they
would be used as a translation tool for
them to translate the message.
And each tablet would have five letters on
it.
Here's a photo from ancient Rome, so they
were using fire to actually
send these messages many, many distances.
But what this system would do, it'd say,
okay, we've got two flames on the left,
that means we want to look at the
second tablet, and then the five flames on
the right means look at the use the
fifth letter on that tablet. And you can
imagine the reason these fire flames are super
super quick,
they can translate and send those messages hundreds
of miles depending on how
depending on what they're using to burn and
what kind of smoke they're getting. But this
was the way that they won wars.
Very cool.
A lot of these tidbits came from the
early history of data networks. You can go
and buy this book. It is quite expensive,
but from start to finish, it is just
such a fun read and I couldn't recommend
it more to people.
Okay. So let's get on track. This is
the talk about InfluxDB,
and we wanna understand
use cases for InfluxDB. And the best way
to do that is to quickly take a
look at the history of time series before
we break down what time series actually is.
So
let's
see.
I guess, you know, having that pop quiz
at the start, we see that, you know,
the ancient Romans did drive a lot of
this
or at least some familiarity of these concepts
that we have in modern times is that
when it comes to when it comes to
time series,
the Romans did that first too.
And in fact,
there's this great paragraph
that says I wouldn't read it verbatim, but,
you know, the things that are highlighted here
are legal bodies
sold to public investors and traded,
and the values of these shares
fluctuated
over time.
Now it doesn't say time series here, but
of course the Romans must have had a
way of tracking the value of the fluctuations
of these commodities
over time to understand
as the
organization or the legal body doing well is
going down, etcetera, and been able pay out
those dividends to the public investors.
So yeah, time series is old even though
it seems to be like something we can
consider
pretty modern.
Some little facts for you is that the
first ever IPO was the Dutch East India
Company in sixteen o two, the first US
IPO wasn't until 1873,
and that was the Bank of North America,
And then it wasn't until 1984
someone asked a question about the price of
wheat.
Why is this important? Well,
this is the first documented
usage of the actual term time series that
I could find.
So this is the first time anyone had
ever put those two words together that was
in some sort of logged and written form
that could
travel the years to today.
But in 1884,
this paper was published in the Journal of
Statistical Society of Lending, which was building comparisons
and looking at the fluctuations of the price
of wheat
correlated with the value or the import price
of cotton and silk into Great Britain.
We're trying to work out if we are
importing more cotton and silk, the price of
wheat can up or down,
etcetera, etcetera.
Now it's not a paper I would encourage
you to go and read.
Of course, it's not that long, so feel
free, but it's just
that was a very nice find to see
time series mentioned in this way.
And, of course, just having
that paper, at least the first one I
could find that was applying the statistical mathematics
to the dimension of time I found really
interesting.
Okay, so
my former boss, Paul Dicks, the CTO of
InfluxDB once said that most data is best
understood in the dimension of time. And I
think that is one of the truest things
that I ever said.
And I'm looking forward to taking you on
this journey of time series and InfluxDB too,
and helping you understand
your time series, your data and your systems.
Okay. With that being said, what is time
series data?
Well, we're going to cover that. We're going
to take a look at
what are time series databases. Some of you
may be familiar with, some you may not
be not. I will get you acquainted with
the vocabulary
of InfluxDB.
And I really want to talk about the
value of time series data. When we talk
about time series data, it's very simple to
talk about the collecting and storing and querying
of that data. But there's something much more
important as we understood, and it's grasping the
value and longevity of that data and being
able to work with it accordingly.
And then we'll talk about a little bit
of those more advanced use cases for time
series, and that's all this is some of
the stuff that we will be covering over
the next couple of weeks on this course.
Okay. So what is time series data? I'm
gonna keep it simple, and it is any
piece of data with a timestamp.
That is it. It's really, really that simple.
If you have a value
and a timestamp, you can track the change
of that value over time and that is
time series data.
Gonna try and do this through an example,
and I'll try and move my face out
the way a little bit. What
we have here
are events, things that could happen in your
infrastructure.
Here we can see that the memory is
100%.
We can see a health check field. We
can see a database migration has been run
and a whole bunch of other things.
But they don't mean much in this form.
Get my eyes back.
But what we can do is try to
identify
what these events potentially represent.
And what we can represent, or at least
what we can try to infer from these
events, are reddy pinky color,
is that these are cause for concern.
These are events that maybe I would want
some alerting on. Like if a health check
failed,
I probably wanna know about it, depending on
how many of them happened and what space
of time.
More on that next
week.
Memory hit a %. Yeah. I probably definitely
want to know about that. That seems quite
dangerous. And pods being killed by the arm?
Yeah. Of course. Right? These are important events
I wanna understand.
Now in the yellow color, what we see
here is potential causality.
So a database
migration ran,
pod restarted,
a new version of our container was deployed,
and we have CI passed and started.
Now these events are not particularly malicious themselves
but they do have the ability to mutate
state.
Something in the system has changed
And change is always the cause of one
of the red ones. Something
has to happen for bad things to happen.
Purple, what do we see in purple? In
purple, see nothing.
Really, these are events that we probably just
want to discard. We would not consider these
things that could cause too much change or
too many problems within our system.
And of course, the red heading in pink,
it's Scotland qualifying for the World Cup.
Never gonna happen.
Now these events, while we can infer what
they mean and we can try to guess
what is happening in the system and its
current state and its current visualization,
we just have no idea. We are flying
blind.
However,
if we apply the dimension of time,
move me back down. If we apply the
dimension of time to these events, we actually
get a really strong understand
understanding
of what happened in the system.
We can actually see
that
the memory hit a %.
We then see that the ARM killed the
pod.
We were probably using the latest tag which
triggered a new deployment of our application, application,
maybe one we weren't ready to deploy just
yet.
That caused a migration to run-in our system
again, which we were not expecting and now
our health check is failing.
We now know what happened and all we
did was
replay these events in the order that they
happened, or at least visualize them in the
order that they happened to build the understanding.
So most data
and data as events with points in time
are always best understood in this fashion. And
that is why time series is so important
and why we're putting this course together on
InfluxDB two.
There we go.
Now, you may already be familiar and have
lots and lots of time series data.
This is the screen that where the words
may not be familiar right away nor even
probably visible to you depending on your screen,
But we've all really familiar with this, right?
This is some log being tailed.
Now, what is the first thing that we
always get at the start of a logline?
It is typically a timestamp.
Logs are classical time series data. These are
events that happen over time that can be
aggregated into metrics.
And I want to make that last little
point really clear.
All metrics,
every single metric in the world, and you
can bring me all the metrics you want
to the Discord.
Every metric is an aggregation of some series
of raw events.
Challenge accepted.
Bring me a metric that isn't. I will
concede, but it's not gonna happen.
What we really want to understand here
is metrics or aggregations always
events of the raw form,
and we have to make trade offs and
understandings of when to store which.
That will also be covered
either next week or the following week as
we dive into InfluxDB
more.
Okay.
So what is time series data?
Well, there are two different types of time
series data as I just kind of covered
in that log back there, but I really
wanna make sure that we understand the difference.
The regular time series, these are aggregated
events or metrics,
are predictable and evenly distributed.
Now what I mean by that is that
I should be able to get the value
for a metric at any given interval and
it should be consistently
available.
If we think about the CPU load average
of a Linux system, as I can request
that value from the kernel every one second,
every five seconds, every minute, entirely up to
me, but there will always be a value.
Much like the temperature, I can always use
the thermometer to get a temperature.
Every regular time series or the raw form
slash events are unpredictable
and very inconsistent.
An example here would be if I am
working on a ticketing system for a football
stadium, I don't know when the next person
is gonna scan their ticket,
but I can tell you how many people
are in the stadium through an aggregation of
the ticket scans over a certain window.
We'll dive into more,
and from probably here on end, will always
reference them as metrics and events rather than
regular and irregular
because it's the vocabulary that you're probably more
familiar with and that we all use every
day in the software and technology world.
Now,
good examples of metrics are CPUs. So you
know I cover this and I mention that
all the time because it's the one that
we're all really familiar with. Memory usage is
another one. I can always get a value
for how much memory is being consumed.
I can always get a ping time for
google.com
even if it's indefinite because it's not up.
And I can always get the number of
processes from a kernel as well.
So these are metrics. These are values that
change over time.
Great examples of events. You cannot predict when
a user is going to click the login
button no matter how hard you try. You
cannot predict when someone is going to get
their
password or username wrong to log into your
system.
You have no idea when an XCI build
is going be published and you definitely
have no idea when a network engineer is
going to trip over a rack and pull
out a cable.
Now, these are still important events and we
can build aggregated
metrics from it, but they are irregular and
unpredictable.
Now I'm not gonna sit on the screen
for too long, but I always like people
to really try and cement their knowledge of
what are metrics and what are events by
looking at a very common example.
If you're a sports fan, I don't even
watch football, I don't know why I keep
using this, but a lot of people do
watch football.
And just by looking at this, there are
so many examples of metrics and events just
in this screenshot.
So I'll pick a couple, but if you
want to try it yourself, feel free to
pause the video now
and see how many you can come up
with.
Now
the metrics that we have available to us,
we can kind of already see.
We have a score. Right? We can see
that Liverpool are beating Barcelona two nil, and
that is three two on aggregate. Those are
two different metrics.
But we also have the raw form of
that, the events that contributed to the score.
We can see that
those two players scored at seven minutes and
fifty four minutes, and that gives us an
aggregated score of two nil.
If we had well, I'm sure someone has
the event data, but we can also see
the other three goals are first one on
the first leg of the match. So those
are the events.
If there were any corners, freeze kicks, red
cards, yellow cards, those are more events that
happened in the game that could be tracked.
The number of people in the stadium is
a metric.
The events are the people scanning in and
out of the stadium and so forth.
But there's a lot of time series data
all around you, everywhere you go, every day
of life. Time series data cannot
unsee it when you know that it's there.
So again, think it's just super important all
metrics are aggregations of events
And it just that should hopefully help your
understanding of this as we move forward.
So the next thing that we want to
get comfortable with when we're doing this in
action on the next video is collecting
time series data.
Now you can do this through Prometheus exporters,
which you may be familiar with if you're
already working with Kubernetes,
or you can use a tool like Telegraph.
It's entirely up to you. They're all great.
They all do a wonderful job. It just
depends on where you're going to be storing
them.
Because this course is going to focus on
InfluxDB
two, we will be using Telegraph for the
majority of our metric collection.
Telegraph is a really cool tool because it
has inputs for almost everything. It's got
at least a few hundred input plugins
where it can read metrics
from, you know, Kafka, Kubernetes, Linux, Puppet, TLS
certificates is a really cool one. It has
remote support for HTTP endpoints, gRPC endpoints, etcetera.
It can write metrics to anywhere. Again, we'll
be using InfluxDB two for this course. And
from Prometheus,
there's always or generally always an exporter equivalent
to the plugin,
which always brings us to the wonderful debate,
push versus pull.
Now
for metrics,
pulling them is fine.
Why? Because they're always available.
They are consistently and predictably available. If I
want to pull metrics on a ten second,
twenty second, one minute, hour
basis,
then that works.
You cannot pull
events.
You cannot pull the raw form because they're
unpredictable.
So you actually need a combination of both,
which is why I always push people in
favor of tools like Telegraph because it can
handle both scenarios.
So you definitely need both. Understand that for
metrics, it's okay to pull, it's encouraged to
pull.
For events, you definitely need push based system
regardless of what you choose.
Now use cases for time series data, why
is this course going to be important to
you? Well, if you're coming from a cloud
native or Kubernetes background, you probably want to
do monitoring.
Infrastructure. You're probably writing applications. You're probably consuming
third party services.
You need to understand how well they're functioning
and where problems arise from good, strong root
cause analysis.
If you're into IoT and centrifugation of the
real world, then you maybe have too many
ZigBee, Raspberry Pis, and other devices around your
home, and you can do so much cool
stuff with all of the metrics that those
are meant day in and day out.
And if
you know, you have your own website, your
own blog, you track your Twitter performance, your
YouTube performance, things that are important to me,
then real time analytics from all of these
services provide really fantastic
time series data.
Okay. Now when it comes to the TSDBs
of choice, this course is focused on InfluxDB
two,
but there are others. But
the thing that I think is important for
right now is
a lot of people do sort their time
series data in general purpose databases.
And there are a few reasons that that's
not gonna work.
Firstly, time series data is generally high rate
frequency.
Right? Especially with IoT and sensorification.
Is that we are writing these
real world metrics
at
milliseconds,
sometimes nanosecond
frequencies or resolution, particularly with
high velocity, high frequency trading in the financial
market.
The way that we read data from a
time series data is also wildly different from
a general purpose database. We're generally scanning large
chunks of data over a particular time window,
so you really want a database that is
built for that purpose.
And then the last part of this session
today is going to be talking about the
value of time series data and time to
live and life cycle management and time sensitivity
of that data
is really, really important and something that you
wouldn't get through a general purpose database.
So,
again,
why is this course important? Well, we take
a look at the trend over the last,
I think, twenty four months. In fact, that
was this is last year's graph. I really
need to update this.
We can see that time series databases are
the fastest growing database category.
And that's because of this migration to cloud
native and Kubernetes.
As we build more and more distributed systems,
we need the tools, the knowledge and the
understanding to be able to operate them efficiently.
Time series databases do that.
Now, there was a really cool
poll that was done by the news stack
that was asking, do you store your time
series data in a time series database?
And only 12% of those people said yes.
So I'm here to see if that is
true. And if not, I want to show
you the truth. Plus, I just really like
Rick and Morty.
Now, you're probably all familiar with New Relic.
It's expensive,
so if you work for a larger organisations,
you may be familiar with it, otherwise you
may not. And if you're not in a
large organisation, you're probably more familiar with Datadog
and
even to some degree, Google Analytics.
These are all time to use databases as
well. Sometimes
we don't really think of them in that
way, but they are tracking metrics and events
that change or happen over time.
So I'm not entirely sure that the NewsDesk
survey took that into account, and I don't
think it's I think more than 12 people
more 12 12 people. I think more than
12% of people are using time series databases
for their time series data.
Here's a question I threw on Twitter a
long time ago, but still has resonated and
stuck with me ever since. But I asked,
you know, I run Kubernetes in production and
I monitor it with.
And there's like a thousand responses to this.
And 74%
of people said Prometheus, which I thought was
great. 3% used in FluxDB.
Yep. That's all good too.
There was some new relic and Datadogs, but
13%
of these people said nothing.
of people are not monitoring their Kubernetes.
That is really scary.
So I hope if you're in that 13%,
you're watching this course,
and you're gonna learn how to monitor Kubernetes
with InfluxDB two. That is our goal. That
is one of the end achievements of this
course, is you will have pitch perfect monitoring
of your Kubernetes system.
Okay. So it's not too late. Let's take
a look at InfluxDB.
Now, none of this is unique to InfluxDB.
This time series introduction thing will probably be
the same introduction to time series that I
give as there is a Prometheus course down
the line.
So this is widely
translatable to any time series database. So please,
even if you're not that interested in using
InfluxDB, you want to use Prometheus or you
want to use M3 or you want to
use Thanos,
all of this is still completely relevant, at
least this one particular episode.
So as far as the introductions go, it's
a time series database. It is completely open
source. They're currently under second version
and FluxDB can set itself full stack and
it has a UI, it has a stream
ability to work on the stream of data
and a whole bunch of other things.
The vocabulary when working with time series data
is typically that we talk about points. So
at any point in time this
being context
was value n.
And if we look at an example of
this, then we can see that the load
average on the machine VM1
was
6.32
at one minutes.
As you know, if we're talking about load
average, it would be 1.515.
Eight point two on five and nine point
five five on 15.
We also have a timestamp in orange. We
have to track the time this value was
recorded otherwise not time series data.
And as far as InfluxDB is concerned,
values are fields
and the context,
the tags, the series is the bit on
green.
Typically we would call the load to be
the measurement, host would be a tag key,
and VM one would be a tag value,
and we break that down here too.
So we have the name or the measurement
name at least in yellow,
tag keys in green, and tag values in
blue.
Now tags are indexed, so it's really important
to make sure you get that distinction as
correct
as soon as possible when you start storing
your time series data.
Here's another example where we could see that
the series changes. Even though the market is
the same, the ticker is different. The series
is actually a triple of the measurement name
and the tag keys and the tag values,
and that's important too,
especially
in around
We'll touch on a little bit next week,
but more so the following week when we
start to really understand how to use Flux
to query
and build dashboards with this time series data,
understanding what a series is particularly
important.
Now, when you're trying to decide what to
do with your time series data, what to
store as tags and fields, remember tags are
indexed and always strings because of that constraint,
whereas fields are not indexed and you can
use multiple data types.
Now
I think the value of series is the
most important part of today's session. Yes, everything
we've covered so far from the fun to
the
intricacies of time series is hopefully really relevant
and I hope you enjoy it. But I
think this part here
is super important to understand because as
you come from your development engineering, the SAP
background,
and if you haven't worked with time series
before, you may fall into the trap of
storing a data forever, and it's really important
that you don't do that because it's really
expensive.
Very, very, very, very, very expensive.
Maybe my cursor back. There we go.
So when we talk about time series data,
we'll talk about frequency and resolution.
Language is interchangeable almost, but I prefer to
use
high and low resolution.
When we talk about resolution, we're talking about
the interval, that predictable interval of the metrics
and how often we collect that data.
So a ten second resolution means we collect
the values every ten seconds. Ten nanosecond resolutions,
then we collect that every ten nanoseconds and
so forth. A one error resolution is a
lower resolution than ten seconds, which is higher
resolution because we collect the value more frequently.
The
value of the time series data that we
collect is directly correlated
with the resolution that the data is available
or collected.
Meaning,
storing
time series data at ten second resolution
is potentially or definitely more valuable to you
than collecting it at an hour because
you
will have much finer understanding
of those values changing over time to be
able to do predictive analytics,
anomaly detection, and a whole bunch of other
things on it. If you only collect the
value every hour or even like every day,
it's not as valuable to you anymore. Think
about the weather patterns and your region.
If you check the value every day at
noon and see that it's 25 degrees Celsius,
it doesn't tell you anything else about that
day.
If you click the temperature
every
ten minutes, every fifteen minutes,
you then have a much better picture
of the daily cadence or
patterns of that temperature
over months, years,
decades,
and centuries.
So the cost of time series data is
installing that resolution.
I'm going to do this through example. Let
me drag my face again.
So
cursor,
very professional this course.
So here's an example. We're gonna use load
averages. I'm hoping that you're all familiar with
this. Over here we have a machine,
we have a single tag, machine equals ABC
one. We're collecting the CPU measurement.
Not gonna call it load average, we're not
gonna do one, five, and 15, we're just
doing single, single usage for now, and then
we have a timestamp.
Now for us to monitor this machine with
a single measurement, the CPU,
one series, which means one machine, at one
second resolution, which means collecting a CPU value
every one second,
that is 86,400
points per day.
Now
as we run through this scenario,
please, please try
and think about using a general purpose database,
your database of choice, whether it be MariaDB,
Postgres, MongoDB, Cassandra, whatever, and try to think
about how the burden or the tax you
would have to pay to store these values.
So 86,400
probably doesn't make you uncomfortable. You're probably okay
with that every day.
Now if we have two machines on our
infrastructure, because it's unlikely we have one machine,
so we have two CDs, we've still got
one measurement, we're only tracking the CPU, and
we're still doing one second resolution,
we double that value to a 72,800
points per day.
We're probably still okay with this regardless
of which database you're using.
Okay.
Let's assume we have 10 machines,
still one second resolution, only this time
we're a bit smarter. We know we don't
just
know that we're not just worried about the
CPU
of our machine. We're worried about the memory,
and we care about desks, and we care
about network,
and maybe there's something else on there.
But five measurements.
We're now at a much larger number
because we've got 10 machines and five measurements
at one second resolution.
So we're now tracking millions of points
per day.
And,
you know, infrastructure
is not typically 10 machines. Right? We probably
have a lot more than that, especially for
production. And we definitely have a lot more
than five measurements. We're not just tracking five
superficial metrics from a Linux host. Our applications
are met hundreds,
if not thousands of metrics.
But I don't know what your infrastructure looks
like, so I'm gonna use the Nasdaq as
an example instead. And we're just gonna track
one measurement, which is the cost or price,
the share price of a ticker
on the Nasdaq. The Nasdaq has 3,300
roughly companies,
and we're gonna do one millisecond resolution.
Because, you know, financial trading, we need these
values.
But look at that number. And that's I
I don't even know what that number is.
I'm not gonna try to guess. Let's just
say billions. That is definitely billions, but points
per day. Imagine storing this in your database
of choice.
But if that time series database,
yes,
it's a lot,
but it's manageable.
It's definitely doable
because time series databases are built to handle
this particular use case.
Now if we drop the resolution,
and this is the most important part now
is that we're talking about resolution change in
time series data.
So we've went from one millisecond to one
minute.
We're down to a very manageable number of
4,000,000 again.
And if we drop it again to one
hour,
we're into the thousands and we're looking at
this and we're comfortable regardless of database, restoring
this value again.
And that's concept of changing the resolution of
data is super important in time series.
At six hour resolution,
we could store this in any database.
We're
not gonna be worried about 13,000 points per
day.
Here's my wonderful diagram
trying to understand
and explain to you the value of time
series data. And I drew this myself, shocker,
very, very cool. Now what we have is
that for a certain point in time,
data at a ten second resolution
has value x.
However, there's a certain point in time
and who knows what that is, right? It's
very specific to the types of data you're
working with, and as we work through this
course, we will spend a lot of time
talking about the value of the metrics that
we collect. But for now, we're gonna keep
it superficial.
But this value, the value of this data
at ten second resolution is important until a
certain point when it isn't.
Now
there's normally a rather large cliff, whereas the
value just drops
and then it's valuable
for a little bit more time and drops
and then valuable for a little bit more
time and drops and valuable and so forth.
Until the data is just not viable at
all anymore.
And one of the things that we really
need to get good at and understand as
we store more and more metrics and raw
events and times of each data enter our
system
is being able to understand that if we
lower the resolution,
we minimize the drop in value.
The value of the data is gonna be
continually,
the value versus the resolution of the data
is gonna continue to be
It's gonna be valuable for longer. Wow.
So if we can actually take that those
values that we store at ten second resolution,
drop them to hourly resolution, you're calculating a
mean as an example
over the hour,
because we're storing less values, the value increases
and the resolution,
yes, we change it, but it's still valuable.
Then we do it again.
After a certain amount of time, we say,
okay, we don't need an hour resolution. Let's
calculate the mean over six hours.
We're storing less data, reducing the cost and
the burden of storing that data and increasing
the value of that data.
Even though the value will increase a little
bit because we lose a resolution, as we
go further away from the point in time
the value is stored,
actually works really well. Eventually, we'll have this
really nice cascading downsampling system where we take
all of our time series data from ten
seconds to one hour, to six hour, to
one day, to a week, to a month,
whatever. It comes down to the types of
data you're storing. Again, we will explore this
in a lot of detail
over the next episodes, the next lectures.
The time sampling is really important,
and we have to understand when to lower
the resolution
of each type of data that we store
in a system and understand the value that
we need from it. Some values, some data,
you will need to keep the higher resolution.
Some data, you will just bend because it's
no longer relevant at all, but really for
long term retrospective analysis of that data, you
will want it in some form.
Now, this is what a continuous query would
look like in InfluxDB
one. It uses a SQL like language.
This is a lot easier to understand than
Flux. We haven't really touched on Flux yet,
so I'm not gonna show you that, but
we will be diving into Flux and you
will see how to do this through Flux
tasks.
But really what I want you to understand
is how the semantics or the pseudo code
of a downsample or a rollup would
look.
So you can see here that we create
a roll up that runs on a certain
bucket or table or measurement.
We basically tell it how to calculate the
mean, and that could be a min or
max, mean, it could be whatever calculation you
want,
and we tell it how to group that
value. So if we have ten second resolution,
we can group by time of one hour
and calculate the mean. And we just let
that
downsample run forever
doing the thing we need. We chain these
together to go from one hour to six
hours, from six hours to a day and
so forth.
So I'm hoping that this InfluxQL version of
it
helps cement what a downsample will look like,
and we'll tackle the flux as we move
in to subsequent
lectures.
Now you cannot downsample events.
Feel free to Google anomaly detection with InfluxDB.
We will be doing a little bit of
it in this course as we try to
use HTTP queries to pull out,
you know, five hundreds, four hundreds, ones that
we didn't expect. So we'll do a little
bit of this, but there is a lot
of prior research on Google available if this
is one of your main drivers for this
course.
We'll do a little, but not a lot.
Excuse me.
Okay. So now that we have our time
series data, we're done sampling it. We've got
it in our InfluxDB database. We're starting to
put things together.
What are some of the things we're going
to cover on this course? Well,
let's do this by example again.
Let's assume you have an application that speaks
to a database.
I call this the simple days, the monolithic
days. You know, back in the early two
thousands where this is mostly how we built
applications,
and if you're still building applications like this,
you know what? For some scenarios, it works
great, good on you. Your monitoring is a
lot easier than cloud native monitoring.
Now, if we want to understand
what to monitor in this system, it's really,
really, really simple.
We typically wanna monitor the CPU to go
above a certain threshold. That means bad things
are gonna happen. We wanna monitor the memory
consumption.
Bad things are gonna happen. If our customers
have a response time greater than three hundred
milliseconds, bad things are happening. We need to
fix it. We may also have predictable
problems.
Black Friday and other holiday and seasonal items
and cadence and things that happen that you
will understand within your domain.
Okay,
so
how do we know when to send an
alert in this system?
Well, we can have an application health check
and if that begins to fail, we send
an alert and if any of those symptoms
that we've seen in the previous slide happened,
we can send an alert.
Really, really simple architecture,
really simple to work with. Time series data
does not have to be terribly complex.
As we start to bring horizontal scalability,
things get a little bit difficult, and this
is where time series data, you then need
to start manipulating it and working with it
in more sophisticated fashion, grouping and windowing and
other things. And we're gonna cover all of
this.
But the question here is how do I
know when to send
an alert with a system?
You know, we can't just use a health
check on a single node because we may
have two, seven, a hundred other of them
that are returned in a good health check.
Well, my face is always getting in the
way.
Please stand by.
So
what we could do is an aggregation of
our metrics, and we can actually look to
see if, you know, using service level indicators
or having a service level objective that we
have to meet, whether we have x number
of 500 exceptions within n window periods. So
whether I have more than 100, five hundred
exceptions within a five minute period, to me
that is a problem that goes against our
service level objective.
Yes, we definitely have to send an alert.
All right.
What about cloud native hell?
So this is the system we have now,
right? We've got service A that speaks to
database A, we've got service B that speaks
to database B, we've service B that speaks
to database B because it's horizontally scaled. We've
got service C, which speaks to database C,
which also has Canadian deployments and progressive deployments.
Of course, all of our networking is virtualized
because it's on Kubernetes and we're running through
the service mesh.
Help
me.
How do I know when this system is
healthy and how do I know when to
page someone?
Time
series data is the answer.
So
we're going to
specifically work on this example. We will have
a Kubernetes cluster. We're going to have InfluxDB
too. We're going to collect data from that
cluster
and we're gonna break the system,
get our alerting into place, and really try
to build as much understanding
through time series as we can.
Now this is the cloud native architecture, convenience
versus cost, So yes, you can still follow
along with this course and learn a lot
if you've got monolithic architectures. There's still a
lot of great knowledge here to understand. We
will be looking at microservices monitoring them using
the Prometheus exposition format with InfluxDB too.
Now, one of the things that we
want this course to help you do is
to root cause analysis and understand causality within
your system.
So we will be breaking into some of
the statistic.
We were exploring
the statistical functions
provided by InfluxDB.
We've able to analyse weeks, months and years
of data using tags to build correlation,
looking at how we can use linear prediction
derivatives,
median absolute deviations,
moving averages, whole winters,
not machine learning, but statistical
learning or statistical predictions based on previous data
and cyclic data structures.
So if you want to know how to
understand the data,
this is a really good way to do
it.
We'll be covering all of these functions at
InfluxDB
across the next couple of weeks.
And some examples here, I like to lean
on my own previous life as an SRE
here,
but
I have been paged at 4AM because a
disk usage of a machine went above a
certain threshold, would trigger PagerDuty alert and wake
me up.
Some of the things we'll explore in this
course is, but how can we actually try
and predict these outages
during office hours?
That is not always possible, of course. Bad
things happen and spikes happen and those are
very difficult to predict. But when we have
linear growth of a disk, yes, we want
to be able to learn that before
I go to sleep.
So we can do that.
We can also use, you know, we have
distributed applications,
distributed HTTP requests. We wanna be able to
use
histograms.
Now there are two ways to do histograms
in time series data. You can use histograms
of metrics where you preassign the buckets within
your code.
There's the slightly better format, but more expensive,
and we'll cover that trade off as well
in the coming weeks,
of where I can store the raw events
and how long every request took and build
dynamic histograms with dynamic bins to understand my
application.
And then some use cases, you may wish
to go down just the
pre allocated bin hardcoded in your code. Again,
trade offs. You have to understand them. You
have to understand the risk and the cost
with both, and we'll talk about that.
Here's an example of the Prometheus one. I'm
saying beware because it's really difficult change these
buckets retroactively,
and we'll have examples of this in the
next week or two.
Proactive operations. One of the really great things
I want us to try and take away
from this is some of those really cool
predictive things that InfluxDB offers, being able to
understand and make predictions
of
previous events. Now we'll probably use an example
like Black Friday and this course where we
take a look at artificial
data of three years of a store
and see if we can predict what the
utilisation of infrastructure will be the following year.
And we're going to do that through applying
the whole winters
to the machine to the time series data
that we have in our system.
Alright, let me pop back over here.
So that is our
introduction
to
time series data.
Now we haven't looked at InfluxDB two yet.
We haven't collected any time series data yet.
We haven't stored it, we haven't queried it,
we haven't built dashboards, we haven't built alerting,
and we haven't done downsampling and analysis of
our data.
This is the introduction. This is lecture one.
There will be many lectures in this course.
We will be doing
thirty minute to sixty minute videos multiple times
per week as we explore time series data
via InfluxDB two.
Hope this has been a pleasant and enjoyable
introduction to this course.
Please remember to, if you're not already, sign
up and become a Rawkode Academy
incubating member to see all future episodes on
this course. We also have new courses launching
in August. We have a course on eBPF
as we look at building and trace points
into the Linux kernel to do really cool
stuff. BPF is a very awesome technology, and
I'm very excited to share that with you.
We also have other courses coming,
and they will all be announced to incubating
members first.
I
hope you will join us on this journey.
Thank you for supporting this channel. I hope
you have a wonderful day, night, morning, whatever
time you're watching this. And remember
to stay tuned.
There will be Q and A sessions and
prerecorded videos coming that will guide you through
the workshop course.
If you do not have access to the
workshop course yet, it is available on GitHub.
The link will be in the show notes
as soon as possible, again, for incubating members.
Have a wonderful day. That's BT Elson.